little sensitive you know the gas pedal
Marie Porter has been a professional
driver for a decade I get to travel
around see all kinds of things but today
her drive is a bit different see her
truck is in Alameda California and she's
well she's at a startup office in San
Francisco driving the truck remotely
like playing a video this remote work
may be all that's left for human drivers
if robots take the wheel I think it is
the future but what kind of future will
it be as this technology unfolds it's
going to be extraordinarily disruptive
self-driving vehicles may make traveling
down the highway safer and more
efficient but they may also upset one of
the most common jobs in America
[Music]
that side mirror to porter drives for
Starsky robotics a San Francisco startup
with an ambitious vision of the future
of trucking we came out of this from the
gate hoping to make trucks drive without
a person sitting on them that's why what
we're doing is we're making trucks
autonomous when they're on the highway
but teleoperated or remote control off
of it
Starsky isn't the only company trying to
cut costs with autonomous technology
last year Wired rode along with startup
Auto as it made its first autonomous
delivery and companies like peloton and
Volvo Trucks are also working on
platooning rigs together for efficiency
trucking with its long stretches of
autopilot ready highway may be the first
part of the driving industry to be
automated at scale I personally wouldn't
want to be a truck driver unless one of
the most common jobs in America computer
scientist Sebastian Thrun laid the
groundwork for making self-driving
vehicles a reality more than a decade
ago I bet many of our truck drivers
actually very creative people just get
no chance to be creative because they're
sitting in this truck all day
I think Humanity has always succeeded in
finding more creative and more
interesting jobs than past jobs spend
away I think for somebody to say well
they're boring and we cut those type of
boring jobs out of out of the mix I
think are naive to why a lot of people
go to work they go to work to support
themselves and their families they don't
necessarily love what they do
union leader Rome Elise says his members
are worried their concerns are their
jobs you know what's going to happen are
they going to be replaced are these
trucks going to have somebody in them to
some drivers autonomous trucks still
feel like science fiction I don't see
any chartered where I bought it to us
it's like another idea like the flying
car is it gonna happen you know they
just probably try it I don't know when
this is gonna happen do you know when
it's gonna happen
but Marie Porter Starsky remote test
driver can see change on the horizon I
know it I'm gonna put me out of a job
yeah and it might be more than just her
job driving from taxis to trucks employs
nearly four
million Americans proponents say
autonomous vehicles could make getting
around more efficient less expensive and
safer it's potentially going to save
hundreds of thousands millions of lives
and but the other side of that is that
it's going to put millions upon millions
of jobs at risk truck driving is
actually the most common occupation in
nearly 30 US states and it's of course
one of the few remaining blue-collar
occupations that is really reliable and
pays that good solid middle-class income
truckers earn a median 41 thousand
dollars a year many make more but
there's a shortage of roughly fifty
thousand truck drivers in the US and
that's likely to grow and that's because
trucking isn't easy just ask Ali Knight
it's a hard life you actually have to
maintain a large vehicle over the road
for three to four weeks even a couple of
months at a time it's definitely a
lifestyle it's not just a job morning
internet night has parlayed her driving
time into a side hustle as a YouTube
vlogger
she's cautiously optimistic about the
self-driving future I may actually get
more filming done which would be great
when she blogged about that auto
delivery run her fellow truckers weighed
in and a lot of people were immediately
turned off by the idea of having a
computer driving a massive vehicle like
this they don't trust them they don't
think that they can handle it they don't
think the data or the technology is
there some autonomous driving experts
agree and say it could be decades before
we see fleets of driverless trucks on
the roads it's relatively easy to stage
a demonstration that does something that
looks impressive and it looks like it's
ready but to get to the point that a
system is really ready for public use is
vastly more complicated and challenging
than doing a one-off demo Steve Slava
has been working on self-driving vehicle
technology for more than four decades
the critical aspect of that is making
the system safe what do you have to do
to ensure that that system is going to
behave properly under every condition
it's going to experience this is
something that drivers do all the time
but getting a software system to be as
responsive to unexpected circumstances
is still a huge technical challenge
Knight says just the weather that she
sees on a drive is enough to give her
pause about computers taking the wheel
at least right now ice snow heavy rain
tornadoes
there's so much stuff out here to deal
with on a daily basis on the day we rode
with night she had to crawl under her
rig and hammer on her brakes to get them
to work that's just one of the scenarios
she thinks will keep drivers like her in
the cab even if they aren't actually
doing most of the driving banging on
frozen brakes with a hammer to loosen
them up so that your tires start rolling
checking the oil level and replacing the
fluids checking your coolant
but it's TASKE the plan is to take the
human out of the truck entirely highway
driving will be computer controlled and
drivers like Porter would remotely pilot
the first and last difficult miles what
we're hoping to do is to make driving go
from a job where you're we're spending
weeks in isolation to to an office job
where you go in you have your friends
you talk talk about the game with or on
the watercooler then you sit down you
work a you know a couple hours and maybe
go take a bathroom break you'll work a
couple more hours
whether starsky's plan is the future
remains to be seen but everyone can
agree there's a shift coming to trucking
we're getting closer every day it's
going to happen most definitely gonna
happen
[Music]